there are two gifts that men
historically never wanted to open on a
holiday we're talking socks and
underwear well over the years socks have
become trendy and now it's underwears
turn Jamie wax is here with more Jamie
good morning
good morning guys yes these are not tube
socks and tighty whities entrepreneurs
are disrupting this once-sleepy category
into one of the fastest growing sectors
in fashion and they've done it in part
with free advertising from celebrities
like Howard Stern and Kevin Hart who
can't stop mentioning their
unmentionables this is really good man
yeah I'm happy for you do this is
amazing
earlier this fall comedian Kevin Hart
stopped by the set of his latest
starring role the new offices of a men's
underwear company I want to switch
things up around here well Charlie's
computers around the face the other way
playing the role of the straight man
sidekick Tom Patterson founder and CEO
of Tommy John I want to put hardemann
every tape but this unlikely pairing is
not the scenario of hearts next comedy I
was a frustrated medical device salesman
wearing a suit and tie every day in my
undershirt seemed to be form-fitting for
UPS box so I thought what if I buy some
fabric take a sketch to a dry cleaners
that has a tailor a couple blocks down
from the street and December make some
prototypes do you remember how you felt
the first time you put the t-shirt you
designed on I was jumping up and down I
was actually doing headstands against
the wall to show my wife how it doesn't
come off it doesn't come undone Tom
Patterson and his wife Erin launched the
company eight years ago to get his
patented state tuck guaranteed shirts
into department stores
Patterson turned his technique to
underwear it's a plot twist that earned
him a very influential customer so we
had an employee come up to me and said
Tom Tom Kevin Hartz dancing around and
our underwear on Instagram she shows me
on a mobile phone I'm like that's pretty
cool you were a customer you bought the
product at a department store yeah we're
on a road and we're in a store and I'm
like man I just need some underwear I'm
out you know last name would be on the
roads dude with a dirty drawers join
everyone fluffy drawers inside
out and get another use of them so I
went to the store I stumbled upon
something I felt them how's that Oh five
soft these are hard my friends I'm like
oh my Tripoli song no they solve well
I'm gonna get them with 95 million
social media followers and upwards of
eighty seven million dollars in earnings
last year from movies and stand-up heart
has become one of the most influential
people in the world but the
self-described authentic comedian wanted
to be less show and more business some
people can just be a NASCAR by NASCAR I
mean you got stickers all over you well
at some point in time people can see
through that these are the nineties man
they just fit good in a hole
celebrity endorsements made men's
underwear trendy in the early 90s but
Hart wanted to be an investor not just
an ad man at first patterson wasn't sold
on the idea did you like that that they
weren't really looking for you I had to
convince him I had to convince him that
I was and I a good idea which pissed me
off
because I was a big deal of time I was a
real big deal at the time so I didn't
like the fact that I had to convince him
that this was the way to go I had to
explain to him I just want to be a part
of what I love like I honestly love your
brand that's when I said let me put my
money where my mouth is let me invest in
your products you can see how serious I
am there's a lot of money being invested
in men's undergarments these days it's
become a multi-billion dollar industry
with startups from coast-to-coast
including me undies in Los Angeles every
month we come out with new designs
Jonathan show Korean launched his
company as an online only subscription
service for men in 2011 his undies
derived from beech trees sourced from a
company in Austria the elastic fibers
from Italy the company says it sold more
than three million pairs I just felt
like there was a disconnect between what
was being deemed as premium wasn't
indeed premium and really wanted to kind
of set out to create a more affordable
product that's extremely comfortable and
a brand that resonated with people these
days they offer underwear ala carte for
men and now women they even offer
his-and-hers how
a guy go from finance to underwear whoo
I guess I had a little bit of a midlife
crisis the undie CEO Brian Lala's areand
left a career in banking for boxers to
make it easy for the customer we've
really categorized all of our colors
classic meaning bold navy gray things
you can wear everyday bold meaning
purple bright colors Pink's greens etc
and then adventurous is kind of where we
go wild I'm wearing all black I mean I
tend to wear really simple on the
outside but on the inside only I know
today I'm wearing pink doughnuts back at
Tommy John they're celebrating their two
millionth pair sold along with CEO Oh
John whoo they have 57 employees
including a seven-person design and
development team solving problems like a
more efficient fly and other touchy
subjects talking about a quick-draw fly
an Oh wedgie guarantee these are
problems that guys have every other
brand has been scared to talk about or
not comfortable talking about do we not
know that our underwear could be better
and more comfortable you have to teach
the consumer that that's a great
question you know when he's saying no
wedgie guarantee you don't think about
things like that until you go through a
day and you didn't pick a wedgie one
time you go man wait a minute normally
at 2:00 o'clock I'm picking wedgie some
3:30 I picked a wedgie yet what do I
have that comes at a cost with trunks
averaging $30 and undershirts $40 you
have to find sewing partners fabric
partners that can really bring this idea
into a product and it's typically more
expensive what is the reaction you get
from people when they see the pricing of
your garments let's say the most common
reaction is wow that's expensive but
once they put it on priced usually
becomes an afterthought over 60% of our
customers come back and buy an item
again after their first purchase what we
hear Moses I really got it and
understood it after I wore it and
according to Patterson and heart when
the curtain comes down it all comes down
to comfort you know when you put on two
pair underwear and you put them on you
oh man I feel good in these
and I'm gonna do I feel good but I I
look good
my other one had a little droop in the
butt my waistband got a little loose
after I put them on huh this is
different is this how it's supposed to
be what if it is you know what I want to
feel like this every day
those are the most inspiring words I've
ever heard about underwear because they
the same is essentially reaffirming the
amount of hearts investment hasn't been
disclosed but the company says he has a
meaningful equity stake which makes him
a partner and co-owner of the company
Jaime wax thank you for that package
thank you very much